as technology has made special effects
more accessible and CGI sets have become
cheaper to build than real locations
studios are more and more tempted to
rely on computerized effects to tell
their stories movies have become servile
ient and digital effects that their
original footage is often completely
unrecognizable from what you see on
screen here's what these movies really
look like before the special effects
were added the revenant leading man
Leonardo DiCaprio and director Alejandro
G Inarritu weren't the only ones to gain
recognition for their work on 2015 sir
revenant
from riding a horse of a cliff to an
epic bear attack I am the digital team
behind the film special effects had
their work cut out for them the true
hero of this film though was Glenn Ennis
the six-foot-four stuntman who played
the iconic bear it was hard on the body
so you know on your hands and feet
picking someone up throwing them around
and it's also admitted that the karpio
was a pretty intense coaster the
a-listers agony was so believable that
Ennis thought he was actually hurting
him
passengers despite failing to recoup is
110 million dollar budget nobody could
deny that 2016's passengers looked great
director Martin Tilden wanted to keep
the visual effects as subtle as possible
effects company MPC was behind many of
the film's iconic shots including a
beautiful zero gravity water sequence
however those special effects may be
accessible they certainly aren't cheap
MPC's visual effects supervisor pd
untold arts of VFX Morton's aesthetic is
definitely biased towards invisible
effects and where they couldn't be
invisible by nature to keep them
restrained and to never distract from
the drama Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice Warner Brothers maxed out their
250 million dollar budget for Batman vs.
Superman dawn of Justice and although
the film made tons of money critics
still weren't impressed director Zack
Snyder received a lot of flack but he
claimed that he and his effects team
actually went out of their way to pay
homage to the source material take
Superman's cape for instance the effects
supervisor Brian he wrote ER
told arts of VFX it had to act and feel
natural but on the other hand behave in
an art directed way and create appealing
shapes that remind the viewer of the
original comics that may sound like a
nice detail but it's a safe bet that
everyone was too busy trying to spot
actor Henry couples CGI raise mustache
in Justice League to go back and notice
the Hunger Games Mockingjay part 2 The
Hunger Games franchise split its final
book into two movies and most fans agree
that a second was far more exciting than
the first VFX supervisor Charles Gibson
it's a scribed Mockingjay part 2 as a
war film with massive set pieces saying
we had to enhance battle action and
create believable environments that
would hold up for extended coverage
working closely with production designer
Phil Messina Gibson agreed on a mix of
shooting on location and building
digital sets saying that Mussina's input
on the project and his design approach
were invaluable
okhta south korean director bong joon-ho
turned countless Netflix users vegan in
2017 with oak J the touching story of a
girl and a super pig VFX supervisor a
Ricky on the boar explained that the
success of the film hinged on whether
the audience believed that oppa a
genetically engineered pig was real as
he explained that no film school the
only way that people are really going to
believe media and oppa and their little
pet friendship is if we have a lot of
contact and if that contact is truly
believable in order to achieve this
physical contact the VFX team created a
range of foam props for young star on so
here to interact with including a full
bodysuit for the most intimate
interactions
fortunately the effort paid off a so
just struck a chord with both viewers
and critics alike Blade Runner 2049 the
sequel to Ridley Scott's seminal sci-fi
classic Blade Runner was a long time
coming and the VFX team felt the weight
of the 80s cult classic on their
shoulders overall visual effects
supervisor Jon Nelson told arts of the
effects any fan of science fiction or
cinema has a great deal of reverence for
the original blade runner' myself
included Blade Runner 2049 cityscapes in
particular or a huge job and multiple
VFX companies were hired to craft this
world in miniature while the film fell
below box office expectations it did at
least managed to capture the neon noir
feeling that resonated with fans of the
originals so strongly
arrival before Blade Runner 2049 at an
EVO nerve directed a sci-fi outing that
was a little more grounded in reality
2016 arrival follows a linguist and the
physicists of the
tend to communicate with an alien
species the VFX style was the polar
opposite of the Blade Runner sequel
seeming drab and washed out in
comparison VFX supervisor and regular
collaborator Luis Morin told VFX blog
V&F wanted nothing to do with any kind
of sci-fi movie that we've been seeing
recently from Hollywood
he just wanted this movie to feel so
real and so boring in so many ways like
ordinary-looking Lewisohn talked about a
cold cloudy day in Montreal but vo never
explained that this was what he wanted a
rival to look like considering how gray
and rub the film looked it's safe to say
he nailed it ex machina Alex Garland's
indie sci-fi drama ex machina beats out
many big-budget films to win the best
achievement in visual effects Oscar in
2016 a calling - VFX supervisor Andrew
Whitehurst the shoot was so well
organized and efficient that they had
extra cash to spend on making Ava the AI
look amazing
he explained that the initial budget
would have only allowed them to animate
Ava's tall 7 limbs and that the extra
money let them animates her head and
neck as well garland also wanted to make
sure
Ava had romantic appeal costume designer
Sammy Sheldon differ explains that her
suit which left little to the
imagination was a massive group effort
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your loved team